josh duggar has been arrested and e.t
has an exclusive reaction from the
duggar family
this is duggar's mug shot taken on
thursday the former reality star was
arrested in washington county arkansas
later that day josh's sister jill and
her husband derek dillard
exclusively told e.t quote we just
learned this information
it is very sad the specific charges have
yet to be revealed by law enforcement
according to tmz duggar is being held in
a detention
center without bail and the outlet says
in 2019
the car dealership where he works in
arkansas was raided in connection to a
federal probe
but it's unclear if that's connected to
his arrest
last week duggar and his wife announced
that they were expecting their seventh
child together
and the pregnancy news follows a decade
of headlines from duggar and the famous
family
in 2015 it was revealed that duggar was
being investigated by police
regarding allegations that when he was
14 he had inappropriately touched five
girls who were minors
statue of limitations prevented any
potential charges from being filed
and we're actually doubling the amount
of grandkids in one year
in the wake of these revelations the
families hit reality series
19 kids and counting was cancelled by
tlc
in a statement at the time duggar
revealed he had made confessions to law
enforcement
and said he quote acted inexcusably
duggar also said his parents
jim and michelle arranged for him to
receive counseling
we we did the best that we knew how at
that point
and we've learned some things since
reporter megan kelly sat down with jim
and michelle on her former fox news show
the kelly fowl i think as parents you
feel like a failure when
one of your kids does something wrong
you feel like
if i had done more training or maybe
something else that this wouldn't have
happened
but the truth is that kids will make
their own choices and they will make
their own decisions even though you've
taught him what's right and wrong
you